in a previous video you saw how looking
at training error and Deborah can help
you diagnose whether your algorithm has
a bias or variance problem or maybe both
it turns out that this information that
lets you much more systematically using
what I call a basic recipe for machine
learning that lets you much more
systematically go about improving your
algorithms performance let's take a look
when training your network which is a
basic recipe I will use after having
trained an initial model I will first
ask does your algorithm have high bias
and so the child evaluate if this high
bias so you should look at really the
training set of the training data
performance right and so if it does have
high bias it's not even fitting the
training set to that well some things
you could try would be to try to canet
work such as what layer's or more hidden
units or you could trim it longer you
know maybe run gains and longer or try
some more advanced optimization
algorithms which we'll talk about later
in this course or you can also try this
kind of a maybe a work maybe it won't
but we'll see later that there are a lot
of different neural network
architectures and maybe even find in
your network architecture that's better
suited for this problem putting this in
parentheses because all those things
that you know you just have to try maybe
to make work maybe not whereas getting a
bigger Network almost always selves and
training longer well doesn't always help
it associate never hurts but so when
training learning other I would try
these things until I can at least get
rid of the bias problems as if go back
after I've tried this until and she's
doing that until I can fit at least fit
the training set pretty well and usually
if you have a big enough network you can
you should usually be able to fit
between training day so well so long
this is a problem that is possible for
someone to generate an image is very
observing it may be impossible to fit it
but if at least a human can do on the
tall so do you think Bayes error is not
too hard and by training a bigger than
network you should be able to hopefully
do well at least on the training set so
these fit to over 30 trainees
once you've reduced buyers to a
acceptable amount I would then ask do
you have a variance problem and so to
evaluate that I would look at the guest
set performance are you able to
generalize from a pretty good training
set performance to having a pretty good
job set performance and if you have high
variance
well best way to solve the high variance
problem is get more data if you can get
it this node can only help but sometimes
you can't get more data or you could try
regularization which we'll talk about in
the next video to try to reduce over 15
and then also again this is a sometimes
adjusted to try it but if you can find a
more appropriate neural network
architecture sometimes that can reduce
your variance problem as well as well as
reduce earlier your bias problem but how
to do that is harder to be totally
systematic how you do that but start
writing a savings in collective going
back and so hopefully you find something
with both global buyers and low variance
whereupon you would be done so a couple
points to notice first is that depending
on whether you have high bias or high
variance the set of things you should
try could be quite different so I'll
usually use the training depth set to
try to diagnose if you have a bias or
variance problem and then use that to
select the appropriate substantive
things to try so for example if you
actually have a high bias problem
getting more training data is actually
not going to help where this is not the
most efficient thing to do so being
clear on how much of a bias problem or
variance problem or both can help you
focus on selecting the most useful
things to try second in the earlier
error of machine learning there used to
be a lot of discussion on what's called
the bias variance trade-off and the
reason for that was that for a lot of
the things you could try you could
increase buyers and reduce variance or
reduce bodies and increase variance but
back in the pre deep learning era we
didn't have many tools we didn't have as
many tools that just reduced bias or
that just reduce variance
hurting the other one but in the modern
deep learning baked into error so long
as you can keep trading a bigger network
and so long as you keep getting more
data which isn't always the case of
either of these but if that's the case
then getting a bigger network almost
always just reduces your bias without
nest recruiting iberians so long as a
you regularize appropriately and getting
more data pretty much always reduces
your variance and doesn't hurt your bias
much so what's really happened is that
with these two steps the ability to
train bigger network or get more data we
now have tools to drive down bias and
just drive down bias or drive down
variance and just drive down there and
without really hurting the other thing
that much and I think this has been one
of the big reasons that deep learning
has been so useful for supervised
learning that there's much less of this
trade-off where you have to carefully
balance bias and variance but sometimes
you just have more options for reducing
bias and reduce or reducing variance
without necessarily increasing the other
one and in fact so as you have a well
regularize network will talk about
regularization starting learning video
training a bigger network almost never
hurts and the main calls to training in
your network that's to base is just
computational time so long as your
regularizing so I hope this gives you a
sense of the basic structure of how to
organize your machine learning problems
to diagnose bias and variance and I try
to select the right operation for you to
make progress on your problem one of the
things I mentioned several times in the
video is regularization is a very useful
technique for reducing Berens there is a
little bit of advisor and trade-off when
use regularization it might increase the
bias a little bit although often not too
much if you have a huge enough network
but let's dive into more details in the
next video so going to understand how to
apply regularization to on your network